quantum physics has a mystique of being
complicated and hard to understand in
fact Richard Fineman who won the Nobel
Prize for his work on quantum
electrodynamics said if you think you
understand quantum physics you don't
understand quantum physics which is kind
of disheartening for us because if he
didn't understand it what chance to the
rest of us have fortunately this quote
is a little misleading we do in fact
understand quantum physics really well
in fact it's arguably the most
successful scientific theory out there
and is let us invent technologies like
computers digital cameras LED screens
lasers nuclear power plants you know you
don't really want to build a nuclear
power plant if you don't really
understand how it works so quantum
physics is the part of physics that
describes the very smallest things in
our universe molecules atoms subatomic
particles things like that and things
down there don't quite work the same way
that we used to up here this is
fascinating because you and everything
around you is made from quantum physics
and so this is really how the whole
universe is actually working I've drawn
these protons neutrons and electrons as
particles but in quantum mechanics we'd
really describe everything as waves by
the way I'm using quantum physics and
quantum mechanics interchangeably
they're the same thing so instead of an
electron looking like this it should
look something like this this is called
a wave function but this wave function
isn't a real physical wave like a wave
of water or a sound wave the quantum
wave is an abstract mathematical
description to get the real-world
properties like position or momentum of
an electron we have to do mathematical
operations on this wave function so for
the position we take the amplitude and
square it which for this wave would look
something like this
this gives us a thing called a
probability distribution which tells us
that you're more likely to find the
electron here than here and when we
actually measure where the electron is
an electron particle pops up somewhere
within this area so with quantum physics
we don't know anything with infinite
detail we can only predict probabilities
that things will happen and it looks
like this is a fundamental feature of
the universe which was quite a departure
from the clockwork deterministic
universe
in classical physics the kind of thing
Newton derived this wave function model
predicts what subatomic particles will
do incredibly well but weirdly we've got
no idea if this wave function is
literally real or not no one's ever seen
a quantum wave because whenever we
measure an electron all we ever see is a
point light electron particle stares
like this hidden quantum realm where the
waves exist and then the world we can
see which is where all the waves have
turned into particles and the barrier
between these is a measurement we say
that a measurement collapses the
wavefunction but we don't actually have
any physics to describe how the wave
collapses this is a gap in our knowledge
that we've dubbed the measurement
problem and this is one of the things
that Fineman was referring to with his
quote another confusing thing is how
exactly to picture an electron it seems
to be a wave until you measure it and
then it's a particle so what actually is
it this is known as particle wave
duality and here's an example of it in
action the famous double slit experiment
imagine spraying a paintball gun at a
wall with two openings in it you'd
expect to see two columns of paint go
through and hit the wall behind but if
you shrink this all down to the size of
electrons you see something quite
different
you can fire one electron at a time out
the slits and they appear on the back
wall but as they build up over time you
get a whole pattern of stripes instead
of just two bands this pattern of
stripes called an interference pattern
something you only see with waves the
idea is that it's the electron wave that
goes through both slits at the same time
and then the waves from each slit
overlap with each other and where the
waves add together you've got a high
probability of the electron popping up
at the wall for where the waves cancel
out the probability is very low so
actually on the back wall the highest
probability of finding the electron is
in the middle of the slits and then it
goes down and then up again and down and
up again and this is the interference
pattern so when you fire one electron
after another they follow this
probability distribution and this
interference pattern starts building up
and that's exactly what we see in
experiments
so this shows that electrons behave like
waves in this experiment the question is
what actually happens to this spread our
electron wave when you do a measurement
it seems like it goes from this spread
out wave to this localized particle but
like I said there's nothing in quantum
mechanics that tells us how the wave
function collapses and this is not only
true for electrons but everything in the
universe so this double slit experiment
has huge consequences for our model of
the universe and it was very surprising
the first time it was done physicists
are still grappling with this question
today and have come up with many
interpretations of quantum mechanics to
try and explain these results and
explain how reality actually works okay
let's go back to the wave function we
can now use this picture to explain
other features of quantum physics that
you may have heard about so this is just
one possible wave function for an
electron but there's many others like
this one for instance this says that the
electron has a probability of being over
here and the probability of being over
here and very little probability of
being in the middle this is perfectly
allowable in quantum physics and this is
where the phrase things can be in two
places at once comes from this is known
as superposition which comes from the
fact that this wave can be made by
adding or superimposing these two waves
the word superposition just means the
adding together of waves and we already
saw this in the double slit experiment
and it's not really a very special
phenomenon you can even see
superposition by dropping two pebbles
into a pond where the ripples overlap
now for entanglement let's say two
electron waves meet their waves
interfere with each other and become
mixed up this means that mathematically
we now have one wave function that
describes everything about both
electrons and they're inextricably
linked even if they move far away from
each other a measurement on one of the
particles like measuring if it's spin up
or down is now correlated with a
measurement on the other even if they
move billions of miles away
Einstein was very uncomfortable with
this idea because if you measure one of
the particles here you instantaneously
know what the other will be
even if it's billions of miles away and
that's got a sort of whiff of
faster-than-light communication which is
not allowed by the theory of relativity
but it turns out you can't actually use
this to communicate information because
the measurements give you random results
but the fact that they are correlated
means that somehow there is a link that
stretches over that distance this is
called nonlocality quantum tunneling
quantum tunneling is where particles
have a probability of moving through
barriers essentially allowing things
like electrons to pass through walls
when a wavefunction meets a barrier it
decays exponentially inside the barrier
but if the barrier is narrow enough the
wave function will still exist on the
other side meaning that there's a
probability of the particle being found
there when a measurement is made in fact
the only reason you're alive is because
of quantum tunneling in the Sun which
makes the sunshine protons normally
repel each other but they've got a small
probability of quantum tunneling into
each other which is what turns hydrogen
into helium and releases fusion energy
all life exists on earth because of
energy from the Sun except for life
around hydrothermal vents now on to the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle I said
at the beginning that this wave function
contains all of the information like
position and momentum of the electron we
just have to do some maths on it the
position is given by the amplitude or
height of the wave and the momentum is
given by the wavelength of the wave but
for this specific wave the position
gives us a probability distribution so
we don't know exactly where the electron
is also there's an uncertainty in the
momentum because this wave is made of
many different wavelengths but we can
reduce that uncertainty let's have a
waiver only has one wavelength so a sine
wave now we know the momentum exactly
because the wavelength is a single value
but look at the position there's an
equal probability of the electron being
found anywhere in the universe ok let's
do the opposite let's make a wave that
has only one position now we know
exactly where the electron is but what's
the wavelength of this wave now the
wavelength is very uncertain basically
only a sine wave gives you a precise
momentum and any wave that isn't a
perfect sine wave
have to build out of multiple different
sine waves in each of those multiple
different sine waves has got a different
wavelength and hence you have a range of
the possible different values of
momentum for the particle this is
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle you
can only know certain things precisely
but not everything either you've got a
definite value of momentum and don't
know anything about position or you know
the position very well but don't know
anything about the momentum or you're in
some intermediate state and this isn't a
limit of our measuring apparatus this is
a fundamental property of the universe
and finally where does the name quantum
come from well a quanta is a packet of
something like a chunk of something and
one of the first quantum effects people
saw were atomic spectra which is where
atoms give off light with specific
discrete energies it works like this
imagine a string that's tied at both
ends like a guitar string if you pluck
it only certain waves can exist because
the ends are tied down in this situation
we say that the wavelengths are
quantized to certain values the same
thing happens if you tie the ends of the
string together because the waves have
to match up they can only vibrate in
certain restricted ways and this is
what's happening to an electron in an
atom the electron wave is constrained by
the atom and quantized to certain
wavelengths short wavelengths have got a
high energy and long wavelengths of a
lower energy this is why the light
emitted by an atom looks like a bar code
because each bar of light corresponds to
an electron jumping from a wave with a
high energy to one with a lower energy
and at the same time emitting a
quantized photon of light when it does
this so the light from an atom is
quantized to discrete packets of energy
okay so that's all the basics of quantum
physics here are some technical notes
which aren't essential to know but pause
the screen now if you're interested in a
little bit more mathematical detail so
to round up in quantum physics objects
are described with wave functions but
when we measure them what we see a
particles so this leads to particle wave
duality and also the measurement problem
and the consequence of these wave
functions are the quantum phenomena of
superposition entanglement quantum
tunneling the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle and energy quantization so if
you understand these things
you've got a good basic understanding of
quantum physics despite its reputation I
think that quantum mechanics isn't too
difficult for most people to get the
basics of what's going on
in the past I've relied on analogies to
try and explain it but here I've just
described what's actually going on which
I think might be more helpful but if
you've got more questions I'll be on the
comments below so ask away for me the
weird thing about quantum physics is
that on the one hand it's incredibly
accurate and predictive but also it's
got giant holes in it like the
measurement problem which we just don't
understand so we can wonder will we ever
actually understand quantum physics or
is it just too abstract for our human
brains to comprehend well I hope this
video has helped you understand a little
bit more about how quantum physics works
and thanks to the sponsor of this video
brilliant org who have just launched
their daily problems which you can dip
into if you've got a spare five minutes
each day each problem teaches you some
interesting facts that you can then use
to solve the problem and if you enjoy
that specific problem there are links to
more on the same topic so you can
develop your framework of knowledge
around that subject and as ever if
you're confused need more guidance then
you can join with the community
discussions so this is a simple fun way
to keep learning more if that sounds
interesting go to brilliant dot org
slash do s or click on the link in the
description below and the first 200 to
do so will get a 20% discount off the
annual subscription which unlocks all of
their premium content well that's it
from me thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]